my channel is sponsored by macarena
which means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of this video
hello everyone wow look at this truly
the highest definition video
i guess aside from my short film that
has ever existed on this youtube channel
i can't i didn't know videos could look
like this
it's so good i probably still have food
in my teeth and usually i don't worry
about that do you see all these pimples
on my cheeks
i'm undecided on if i like it more or
less
in any case i feel like i look like a
different person and i find that to be
quite distracting
uh but really everything looks different
right now because i am house sitting at
a friend's place to look after the
adults which is basically a dream come
true for me and clearly
ethan is a
much more professional content creator
and thus
has a functional
good setup
this is b
and she is a sweet little baby
who really likes to lick mouths
and mostly just
needs a lot of attention which i don't
mind giving her um but really for
today's video
i just wanted to explain something that
clearly i have not explained very well
nor announced very well
nor detailed very well anywhere at any
point um and thus people have questions
it's entirely my fault that we are in
this predicament
i owe enough to that it is also directly
related to the sponsorship that is in
the middle of this video we put the dog
down i don't want to keep her away so
wait ethan has like a button for this
hang on
that seems right okay so if you can't
see anything on the screen that is
because i don't want to change
my friend's setup maybe things will be
cut off
i won't find out till i edit
how exciting so i uh at the start of
this month launched a patreon and it is
very specifically in support of
sort of
my podcast network um and i want to be
super clear that the intention here uh
which is like the most common question
that i got is that no this does not mean
any changes to the existing podcast on
this youtube channel play watch listen
is technically not even included in the
patreon which is something that i also
wanted to elaborate on here because that
is like the second most common question
that i got
idiots and abroad will still publish the
same way that it does every month um red
lips orange car which is a podcast that
i launched like maybe four or five years
ago
is coming back which is super exciting
um because we hit
a patreon goal that i set for the return
of that show but i basically just wanted
to answer like i said the common
questions i've been getting explain what
some of this means uh i apologize for
like hastily just throwing it up and
being like it exists now and then never
talking about it or referencing it ever
again
that is my bad so the patreon is
intended to be run completely
not-for-profit meaning that any money
that it makes will go directly back into
any of the shows that i produce let me
just read my own description it looks
like it's not gonna be cut off
hello and welcome this patreon is here
to offer ad-free versions of all of my
podcasts which will eventually otherwise
have sponsored ad reads with the
exception of players listen um
that that's kind of why i wanted to you
know when i when a sponsor comes to me
it's like hey can we do an ad read i get
to choose what content that it goes in
most of the time not all the time but
most of the time it's kind of why i
wanted to put an ad in the middle of
this video is uh going forward podcasts
will have sponsored ads in them that
means they'll also be in the audio
versions which now they currently are
not and right now they're all just um
youtube ads
that is going to change um they are
going to have sponsored ads um and if
you patreon exists for anyone who does
not want
the sponsored ads in part play watch
listen is the exception because i don't
ever intend to sponsor that show the
reason i don't want to sponsor that show
is because it is like so much just a
labor of love um
labor even feels like the wrong way to
that's probably the wrong term play
watch listen is something that everybody
who is on that podcast
volunteers up their time and their very
busy schedules for we often have to move
things around
um frankly i often am like very last
minute like i can't do it sorry which
sucks for everybody um it's a show that
i don't want to put any pressure on or
financial obligation on i don't want to
make it work for anyone um i think it
being like a hobby that we all really
look forward to every week is why the
show is so good and as soon as it would
turn into something it's like well i
have to do it this week you guys because
i have this sponsorship it has to get
done
i think that would hurt the show so i'm
not technically including patreon
in sorry i'm not technically including
play watch listen in this whole deal
however if it's if it does well um if
the patreon does well and people really
want it i will upload completely ad free
versions to
patreon too because why not
but the actual however is i have
technically already used the patreon
to
justify
um
two expensive things that i have done
for play watchlist and one of which i
will be releasing
on the boys next week that i'm really
really really excited about it's like a
gift that i you know had to pay a
significant amount of money for um so
i don't doubt that the patreon will also
be able to help contribute to stuff for
play watch listen i'm just not
officially trying to uh include it
because i do not intend to ever get
sponsors on that show um and because i
don't want to promise people a certain
amount of content i don't think that
play watch listen could do an extra
podcast um or an extra piece of content
every month which is what i'm doing for
idiots and abroad and will be doing for
red lips orange car when that returns i
just don't think any of those people
which clearly has shown recently that uh
you know now that the world is a little
bit more active we're losing a person
every week or we have to juggle
something around every week
which is our way of continuing to make
the show without going back to the
monthly format
because i don't think any of us want to
do that i would really miss the show if
we had to do that
um
but yes that is the most common question
that i've gotten is like how does this
work with players and i hope that
answers it basically
play watch listen will remain exactly
the same i'm not going to sponsor that
show because i don't want that show to
ever be viewed as work by any of us uh i
want it to continue in the format that
it currently is
but
um
i am using the patreon to support extra
stuff for that show because it currently
runs completely not for profit anyway
technically i'm running that show at a
loss which is really my own fault but
um
it it does not profit so
i can make more cool stuff like the
thing that you guys we have to see at
the end of this week uh with the patreon
money but it's not for that because i
don't want to add obligation anymore
it's basically what i'm saying i do not
want to
uh cause mike or troy or austin to feel
like they have to do any extra work
so it's technically not part of it um it
is more of a
podcast network because i feel like
that's the direction that my channel is
heading in going forward is that i
really like making podcast type content
doing interviews uh talking with
different people for an hour i already
do like game review wrap-up type things
where i talk to different reviewers i've
obviously done
two of the videos with jake and yong and
skill up and i think we'll probably try
to do one of those every six months and
just like more of those kind of
recurring pieces of content where i get
to you know
lean into the 10 plus years that i've
been in the games industry and have
gotten to know a lot of people who are
willing to chat with me so it's
something that i really enjoy doing and
i think people like watching so that's
kind of to support that because that
content is always longer requires more
people
and it's something that i can't edit
myself because frankly i'm really bad at
it i'm a bad audio editor so i can video
edit but i'm bad at mixing audio and i
need to pay people to do it to get
content that doesn't just end up with
comments people complaining about audio
um so that is the main intention uh
we do already have on here i think i put
it in the goals section let me read the
rest of this i guess so
patreon is bringing the return of redux
orange car we hit a goal for that so
that is happening
um oh my god what have i done it is time
to talk about macarena which is a 5v5
mobile combat game i got involved
because they recently partnered up with
ablegamers which is a charity that i
care a whole lot about so i was stoked
to get to work with somebody who also
likes april gamers
macarena is made by polarium who are
best known for their mobile title raid
shadow legends which you've probably
heard of but their latest title mech
arena involves five players going head
to head in custom mechs flinging bullets
rockets and lasers across the map to
destroy the enemy team capture control
points and win you can complete
challenges and participate in events to
get new mechs weapons and more so you
can continue to dominate the competition
the macarena team has challenged people
to destroy as many mechs as possible as
a fun-to-play competitive mobile game
that focuses on a variety of things with
different modes and gameplay styles as
part of this i did recently have a
milestone where the more mechs people
destroyed in-game the more money they
donated to ablegamers and it resulted in
a 100 000 donation which you love to see
but as part of that of course i have
been playing it it's very very easy to
pick up and play it's fast-paced it's
fun and i'm also suspiciously good at it
which makes me feel very good about
myself so that's a huge plus
so if you want to check out mechaarena
the qr code will be on the screen
somewhere right now or you can check out
the link in the description huge thank
you to macarena not only for working
with me but also for working with
ablegamers you love to see it i have
four co-hosts picked for that show if
you don't know that show it's basically
about like
internet dating um but much sillier uh
we take stories from like am i the
[ __ ] on reddit or relationship advice
um it started as just craigslist and
pick like crazy stories and just make
jokes about them it's another one of the
comedy shows so
if idiots and abroad is a travel comedy
show
then red lips orange car is a
relationship comedy show with a little
bit of advice sprinkled in i'm really
excited about the host that i have i
will announce them closer to the return
of the show but it is my first
entirely
uh
women hosted show which i'm super
excited about so then i also
really wanted to make
two more podcasts
the idea would be play watch listen goes
up every friday the others all go up
like
one week a month every monday and i just
realized that i cannot make these shows
these extra two that i think would be
really cool that i really want to make
without a way to support
that endeavor which is paying other
people to help me so that i just don't
get burnt out um and i don't end up
you know just feeling like i'm
perpetually in crunch to make the
content that i want to make
so the first one
which we're pretty close to hitting the
goal for when we hit 400 patrons is what
they what i set that to um i will be
launching a new podcast on the channel
it is going to be called video game
writing 101 and it will feature
uh me talking to different video game
writers every month probably two um in
any given podcast
uh where we will talk about it like it's
a class so the podcast is called video
game writing 101 and it will be like how
did you get started what are the biggest
tips what games do you think have the
best writing what's a challenge that
people wouldn't expect like what was it
like working on this and um
we'll have people from major aaa studios
uh people uh probably particularly on
the picture and have the ability to
request uh any writers that they want to
see on the show um
the first episode i already have
recorded because i wanted to like test
the format
and it has
someone from respawn
and someone from insomniac um talking
about you know their biggest games which
is super exciting i really loved doing
it but i also think that it will be a
less popular show on youtube which is
part of why patreon support helps i do
not think that video game writing 101 is
likely to get many views um
so
the interest and and the help of patreon
is that uh in theory we can use an
audience of people who are very very
into this particular thing almost using
it as a class like like a university
lesson which is literally why i titled
it that where i just don't think that
show
will ever get very popular on on youtube
it's not the
outrage clicks content people wanna
wanna see on youtube
so if i can lean into patreon which is a
much tighter community um to support
that show i will need to rather than
running youtube ads and the intent would
be to eventually entirely take youtube
ads off of all of my podcasts uh in
favor of doing my own ads but patreon
will get fully ad free versions um the
second one
is voice acting 101 uh which is very
very very similar like the same concept
as video game writing 101 except that it
would be all about voice actors um again
i've already locked in some
very cool
huge people um that i think a lot of
people are gonna be really excited to
see me talk about and that was an
extension of having so much fun
interviewing maggie from resident evil 8
on the channel recently that video a lot
of people really enjoyed it was just a
candid conversation with her and i
thought she was so wonderful and i
enjoyed the conversation so much that i
was like why don't i pick two different
voice actors to do this with every month
so we would get one of each of those
podcasts per month plus red lips orange
card that one's already confirmed but um
yeah the video game writing 101 i have
currently at 400 patreons
and then voice acting 101 is at 600 um
i don't know that i really need to keep
those goals but they were just there to
like
gauge interest in
uh in the shows and i have voice acting
101 as a slightly higher amount of
patrons just because that one is going
to be harder to coordinate because i
have to go through their vr people and
potentially have to get approval and
have to do cuts and working with actors
is just a little bit more difficult than
working with video game writers so that
one is a higher tier because it is going
to be more expensive and more time
consuming to produce
but i'm really excited about the idea of
it um we also have
extra content for some of the shows
specifically idiots and abroad already
has
one exclusive piece of content up that i
think is fantastic
it is um uh i would say like dramatic
readings of very low
star
reviews of a brothel
because of course it is um
but i've also
i will also put up this week a
behind-the-scenes video
of rahul and jacob rehearsing
uh
star wars um just extra stuff like that
will will go up on the patreon the
patreon and as part of it uh we are
actually all going to colorado
and uh i was gonna have john edit some
vlogs so i will be paying jon to do that
using patreon money obviously uh it
helps to pay for accommodation so that
the travel podcast actually has us
traveling um and i also like it as a way
to support john in editing uh vlogs as
well so depending on how they turn out
um ideally if we hit this goal which i
think was absurd
a thousand seems unlikely but maybe um
then we will do
monthly travel vlogs once a month uh and
we'll do some meetups as well in any of
the new places that we visit which is
super exciting to me um
and
yeah as it stands right now they'll be
like every now and then when we can
schedule it
when we could afford it uh a lot more
low key
overall um but it will we will have
extra content and i think we spoke about
it on one episode of the podcast
recently
where we were like oh i have this idea
where i like basically i have an idea
for
a comedy sketch slash kind of short with
the idiots in a broad crew patreon will
help to fund that kind of thing in
theory patreon can also help me fund
short films um any extra creative
content that isn't like just let's plays
or unboxings or q as or whatever the
patreon will really help with basically
um but yes the intention is podcasts and
right now
the group that i have is obviously i do
play watch listen i do idiots and abroad
i'm bringing back red lips orange car if
we hit the goals we will have
a video game writing and video game
voice acting 101 um but it could expand
from there right i don't really know i
just needed to make sure that i i can
have support to make them without
burning myself out basically so
that is everything i think that i've
answered all the big questions here
um
yeah i mean i'm taking questions for
both of the podcasts
i asked people on patreon if they have
any any suggestions for our trip to um
colorado to see if there are things that
we should vlog or things that we should
do there and i'm just really excited to
do that so
yes that is basically the plan i again
hope that i've explained it all well i
recognize and apologize for explaining
it very poor previously i have
rightfully been called out for that and
that i literally was just like and it's
here and i didn't elaborate on any
aspect of what it actually is um
but yeah the podcast going forward
we'll have ad reads like the one in this
video uh that will be in both video and
audio versions
and if you want them without that go to
patreon you'll get that for i think if
that one said it
five dollars yeah it is but that is
basically the plan i'm i'm excited to
like
dig a little deeper into the thing that
i think i'm best at on youtube that is
it for me today everybody i feel like i
blabbed a lot but i think i've also
explained it
in hd
wow so crisp
it's very weird i'm so used to being so
blurry it also makes my makeup look
better
maybe
it might make it look worse i don't know
i'll see when i edit this again a huge
thank you to mecarino for sponsoring my
channel um you can check out more from
them in the description and probably the
pinned comment uh otherwise the other
link to the patreon will also be in the
description huge thank you to everybody
who's supported it so far i'm very
excited about liv's orange car coming
back i need to stop talking
that is it for me today everyone i will
see you guys next time bye